400 years ago secure the cargo  a power that couldn't change the course  of history was lost  generations have searched for it now  look at this  it was long claimed the ship was  carrying a secret cargo but no one has  found a clue until now  the model ship conceals a clue don't  have the greatest secrets in all history  I'm warning you  get out but you still can these people  do not play nice  I will find that ship with or without  your help  Thanks  I'm Tintin by the way cutter Archibald  haddock someone thought with or the  Keats no not the sandwich how could you  let them escape there's a guerrilla  fighter ship before we do it's over  she's injustice  he wants fence  until punk  this may sound crazy when I put a plan  did you hit anything over here  when I bang it  you look the little cold so I let the  leave I am in a boat well this is a fine  mess  I love it man  you